ladies and gentlemen ladies and
gentlemen
now I know y'all didn't think I was
gonna make y'all wait another week for a
fantastic four episode no I am not we're
gonna start calling these episodes I
know you didn't think I was gonna make
you guys wait this is arguably the
greatest moment in the history of Marvel
Comics I would say it is the greatest
moment the only one that might be better
than this is when Black Panther gets The
Infinity Gauntlet in in John and
hickory's Avengers New Avengers and when
the when the cosmic entities get
destroyed by the beyonders and the last
ride of thornhub okay so this is a
really cool moment it's not the best but
it's like a really cool moment there's
it's a really really amazing moment all
right check this out so here's the thing
right this picks up with Franklin and
Valeria arriving from the future into
the past in order to basically save the
day now as soon as Franklin gets here
the celestials freak right like these
mad celestials start freaking out now a
lot of you guys were asking in the
comment section why don't the regular
celestials from the main Marvel Universe
show up to fight the match Legends I
don't know who cares because if they had
done that we wouldn't have gotten this
amazing moment here it's Comics roll
with it so here's the thing the
celestials immediately freak out because
they scanned Franklin Richards and we
get the exact same response that we got
when they analyze the younger Franklin
Richards in the last video that we did
right human mutant anomaly beyond omega
classification again reality Distortion
Universal shaper Galactic constant
danger danger Doom right here's the
thing Franklin Richards is what we refer
to as a universal constant right a
reality Distortion guy he is a universal
shaper that's the role of Franklin this
is the reason why the Fantastic Four
Story by Jonathan Hickman and why we'll
probably just kind of release this
remastered Fantastic Four along with the
remastered Avengers and New Avengers
it's why it's so important that's why at
the end of Jonathan Hickman's Secret
Wars you saw Franklin Richards basically
giving form to universes because that's
what he does Franklin Richards used the
power of the molecule man which was
basically the power of the beyonders to
recreate universes and then Reed
Richards was telling Franklin what to
put in those universes since he
remembered everything so literally
Franklin was building whole realities
from scratch that's the role that
Franklin plays now as soon as the
celestials realize what's going on
Franklin waves his hand the celestials
are gone now here's the crazy thing
about this I know it's nuts right it's
absolutely nuts you do kind of have a
conversation between Nathaniel and
Franklin and Valeria because remember
Nathaniel was sent back here before
Franklin and Valeria arrived and so when
they kind of asked the question you know
like whether was there anything that we
didn't account for anything that
happened that we didn't expect that we
need to account for here because
remember cascading changes to the
timesheet which we'll talk about here in
a second that all that really happened
is that the great read Richards the one
that we saw at the end of the last video
he sacrificed himself to save everybody
else but that was basically it now one
of the things Valeria says is that
things looked pretty sketchy when the
revision wave hit the 45th Century but
somehow Franklin was able to pull it
together here's how that works this is
one of the cool things about this you
will likely see this in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe when it comes to King
Dynasty and Secret Wars so this is
something to keep in the back of your
head so the way this works and the
easiest way to explain it it's like a
meteor hitting the Earth right when a
meteor hits the Earth it creates a giant
tidal wave and that tidal wave spreads
out in all directions now the idea of
basically this revision wave the point
of contact the moment when the revision
wave was initiated was basically when
Franklin went back in time visited his
younger self and then gave the message
to Valeria and woke up the powers of his
younger self the reason why that's so
important is because in this example of
a meteor hitting the Earth frankly going
back in time that's the meteor hitting
the planet the tidal wave moving out in
every direction that's the change to the
time stream that's happening as a result
of Franklin going back into the past now
there are a few other things that cause
that as well Reed going in and meeting
the council different things like that
but we'll talk about that here in a
minute because that becomes a very
important point but of course Reed as
Franklin what happened to the celestials
you just destroyed them with a wave of
your hand can you do something like that
and the response of Franklin is no I
didn't kill him I sent them to the inner
sphere of a local gas giant right to the
local star it'll confuse them
momentarily but they will be back and
this will not work again so I'm going to
have to find a way to permanently
destroy these guys now there is a bit of
a moment where you have Franklin kind of
talking to Reed and saying it's been too
long I missed you Dad and that's going
to be the Crux of all of this it's one
of the things that I want you to keep in
mind the focus behind everything that
we're going to see over the course of
this is a son trying to save his father
that's all this is going to be and
that's what made Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four runs so beautiful was
Franklin trying to save his dad now at
that point adult Franklin meets with his
younger self and he asks them are you
ready and the younger Franklin says yes
I saved everything up just like you
asked just like you showed me now of
course when when he asks is it going to
be enough the response of adult Franklin
is I hope it will but I don't know for
sure now here's the thing man anybody
who hasn't read Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four Franklin's got an ace up
his sleeve and it comes in one of the
most baller moments ever in the history
of Marvel Comics oh my God it's so
amazing but the Mad celestials arrive
Frank shows up boom goes right head to
head with these guys and let me tell you
something man this battle is fierce
because it's Franklin Richards in the
future fighting a handful of mad
celestials guys with the power of gods
these dudes are Next Level now while
this battle is going on like Susan and
Reed asked Nathaniel can Franklin defeat
these celestials and Nathaniel simply
says just Franklin against all three
celestials no but hold hope Franklin
will find a way he'll find one because
he has to and when Reed asks why the
response to Nathaniel is I have seen
hundreds of iterations of this day
relived it countless times I've
interceded I've manipulated I've done
everything I could to produce a new
outcome in my every effort has failed
you see son this was the day that all
your sins caught up to you it's the day
that you died but Franklin figured it
out and he wouldn't have it he simply
wouldn't stand for it every boy deserves
a father now here's the cool thing about
this Franklin facing off against these
celestials is nuts because one of them
he annihilates on the Spot while he's
attacking one Celestial he's attacked
from behind by another he literally
flies into the sky punches him in the
face and blows the celestial's head
apart right so one down two to go and he
comes out and this this is let me tell
you something man man
it's just God it's like one of the best
moments ever right because he comes
flying out of this celestial's head like
a he looks eight kinds of piss and I
gotta say man it's one of the best
looking moments ever with his character
right so then Reed ask the question how
did all this happen and the response of
Nathaniel is you walked through the
bridge that's how all this happened it
started when you entered the bridge now
initially Susan Storm's question is the
exact same as Valeria well what if he
didn't and the response to Nathaniel is
the same thing he told Valeria no there
are Universal constants things that
always happen you always walk through
the bridge you always meet that Council
you always meet all those youths with
them you always build Sons you save
universes with them you always wake the
Mad space gods and they always destroy
the council I always helplessly watched
even though walking away you always paid
the price for being a part of it I watch
and there's nothing that I can do and he
says but that's how it is for any parent
isn't it you do everything you can you
do your best and then one day you're
finished and your children have simply
become who they are going to be Now
ladies and gentlemen this is the moment
this is the moment we've all been
waiting for this is the moment that we
as comic book fans have been jonesing
for for the longest time anybody who was
read Jonathan hick was Fantastic Four
knows what I'm talking about and if you
haven't already drawing if it's
Fantastic Four you read it now you need
to make sure you go buy it this this
month this moment right here this is why
we're remastering this whole thing
because because the way we do that four
sucked it was not very good before we're
making it better now here's the thing
Franklin realizing he cannot destroy
both of the celestials by himself ends
up taking the power of his younger self
that's one thing to keep in mind this
whole time he's just been using his own
power he takes the power of his younger
self he channels it into a ball and just
shouts rise and while that's going on
Nathaniel is like this is who your son
will be read this is who he is
throughout all of space and time the
Devourer of Worlds has had many Heralds
Franklin has had only one and Franklin's
just like rise and takes that energy and
throws it into Galactus and he's like to
me my Galactus and he resurrects
Galactus from the dead son Madness man
let me tell you something man
is one of the best moments ever one of
the absolute best moments ever in the
history of Marvel Comics and so
literally what you get here is Franklin
Richards and Galactus a annihilating
these guys and one of the best moments
ever right because like one of the
celestials comes after Galactus Galactus
like come come fail me like destroys the
sky on the spot like riffs his body in
half and like while that's happening
like you literally have like like
Nathaniel telling everybody because
Susan has no idea what's going on she's
like I still don't understand which
doesn't make any sense because you think
that a wife of the the smartest man in
the world arguably would be able to
understand all this stuff because she
spends so much time with him but
literally Nathaniel says all of this
came from rejoining the council being
part of all those reads trying to make
better worlds he left him because he
refused to make the sacrifice each of
them had made he refused to abandon
those he loved for the greater cause
they put the well-being of the
Multiverse ahead of the few which were
their families it was a logical rational
choice but it was the wrong one Franklin
was the one who figured it out the
council built sons and saved universes
they constructed great machines for good
works but because of their choice there
was one thing they were not capable of
there was one thing Reed could create
that they could not that he was able to
create Franklin and that's the important
thing behind all this it's why I say the
entirety and that's why it's so
beautiful the entirety of of Jonathan
Hickman's Fantastic Four it's literally
nothing other than a son trying to save
his father that's literally all it is
it's nothing but that the entirety of
the story comes down to this moment
which is Franklin trying to engineer
things in such a right way that it will
lead to him being able to return to the
Past save the life of Reed Richards and
save the day to keep his family and
everybody on Earth alive and so that's
the crazy thing because Galactus killed
that that other Celestial by ripping him
in half one left right this alternate
reality version of erisham the judge
that literally you have Galactus that
punches a hole through this guy or
shoots a hole through him Franklin flies
into him and then destroys him but in
the midst of of it all it looks like
Franklin is killed in the blast right
literally Nathaniel says look up at the
life you made Reed look at the one who
would sacrifice himself so that all
might live and then we get this just
beautiful monologue right because with
the death of erish and the judge just
this massive explosion we get this
beautiful monologue where it says and
for a moment there were two sons that
day they marched the sky Victorious the
Earth Stood her Heroes the difference
they had endured together Old Friends
new friends and the generation to follow
they watched until the second son
flickered out the light extinguished the
sign of the abandoned the left behind
and the lost but it also meant a second
chance it signaled a new day a future
regained for if we live there is hope
and if we hope then there is tomorrow
and if tomorrow then forever that's
right ladies and gentlemen Franklin
Richards came back from the future to
the Past red resurrected Galactus from
the dead and killed the Mad celestials
arguably the greatest moment ever in the
history of Marvel Comics and absolutely
the best moment ever in the history of
the Fantastic Four I don't care what
anybody says and so what we do here is
we pick up with an epilogue that where
you have Franklin like the adult
Franklin who's still there you've got
kid Franklin and so on and so forth one
of the biggest mistakes that Reid
realized he had made as he had never
really embraced his son as a son which
is to say he always saw Franklin as this
kid who was Godly powerful and instead
of treating him the way a son or father
would treat a son that he treated him as
this kid that needed to be kept safe
protected from his own abilities which
is why Reed put mental blocks in the
mind of Franklin after that old
Fantastic Four story where Franklin
basically turned himself into Jesus yes
that happened yes it was amazing it was
like the craziest display of Franklin's
power up to that point but in this
instance he actually goes the other
direction and says it's okay to be
afraid frankly because Franklin's
terrified of jumping off right like
literally feed is trying to teach him
how to fly trying to teach him to use
his powers and he says it's okay to be
afraid Franklin it's okay to fail but to
say that you're not even willing to try
that's unacceptable and so Franklin
responds and says okay I'll do my best
and so when Reid asks him are you ready
Franklin says I'm I'm ready and so Reed
says good now fly and for the first time
in his entire life Franklin Richards
flies into the sky that is just this is
a beautiful moment an amazing story it's
not the end we still got more left but
it's a ridiculously awesome moment in
the story The the just just is the
greatest moment ever in the history of
the Fantastic Four thank you guys for
watching and I will catch you all next
week peace